Alec Martinez and yeser Bist David poock cuts into
the middle as petrangelo fell down and Thompson
with a great stop on poock he flashed out the
glove to Rob one of the game's best goal scorers
and and petrangelo gets caught with a Deep Gap and
that allows P knock take advantage a little dangle
to the inside goes to the back hand and a great
the three wins have come at home against Ottawa
LA and the Islanders Chandler Stevenson cutting
in and his centering passman off of Danton Heinen
Mark Stone into the offensive end broken up by
lowai Mel barers ship backand and SW got a pit
of it and stone for the rebound wide it's their
struggles Arad picking his way through now Matt
grizzli with a drive deflected and Thompson with
a good left Pat save think Jake rust may have
deflected that Charlie Coyle dumps it in each of
these teams had very similar starts this year the
golden knights were 12 2 and one through 15 Bruins
were 12 1 and two course the golden knights have
slowed considerably over the last month hega Drive
save rebound and W couldn't get a handle on that
lead pass to pav Doria watched by makoy turns up
drive on Save made by San and then he stopped Maro
the first pit came from porzak fell across his leg
lco driving in rolls up and plays it across to Van
reik puts it on net blocked aside by Thompson Loco
cutting into the corner in behind the net van RSD
cut off of the pass by white cloud kisar in the
wing Banks it out W spoon will move it away Howen
picks it up broken up by Wilder spol run b a wrist
shot on and San turns that away Stevenson looking
drops it down for dorv marsh is still trying to
roll free Cent and it's swam and Rob Stevenson
games nice set up by Maro on the doorstep and sing
with another big stop zaka dumps it in olsar back
to get it now turn over shaton kerk a drive on
turned away by Thompson now petrangelo has it
he'll relieve the Heat and lob it to the Boston
line but geeki right up ahead the makoy r shot on
seed Away by Thompson all the way out high but out
of the reach of w fifth time this season they've
been blanked only San Jose with six has been shut
out more foil looking shot on on a save Thompson
Charlie Coyle with a pretty good look from the
left side Jake de brus picks it up looking in
front towards marona tipped away though by White
Cloud makoy across grizzli his shot save Thompson
rebound of makoy down down the wing busting
towards the middle back hands it across the
top of the crease White Cloud lost an edge in the
process in front a save made by Thompson on De
brusk Co with the pass the Martinez getting a look
with that play Marshall that's the pl just don't
force passes take what's there Mar to the net
a backand denied by swingan he's had one chance
right off the rush is mar went all trying to go to
the backand puck kind of rolled a bit but a good
right pad save by Jeremy Swan see almost fanned on
it Stone tips it in first man back for the Bruins
so onean Advantage here for Vegas for a minute and
a half Maro petrangelo looking shot save San Stone
out High throws it on that and Swan swallows that
up till tonight with hmark out injured Stone gains
the line will give him go with barers ship cutting
in treding to center it but has never reached
Mar so get blocked 40 seconds on the power play
Maro in deep Zips it out hi Will M and across to
Martinez Mato Maro Martinez open a WR shot save
San Dano a 14-year Captain before that
markstone bats it down barv in tight
trying to center it lowai able to protect
the house down low final and then they ran
into the golden knights couldn't get it
done chatt C will feed it down Hing with
a wrist shot kicked out by Thompson
grizzli pinching in orzac returning
after a month absence loo turned it over
to cter cter looking WR shot and a safe
San by lyol Aro winds it in Stone gloving it down
feeds it off to Barber Chef sa pass
to Martinez Maro centered attack score
Jack Kel on the doorstep on the power
play and the golden knights break the
ice starts on the rim can't get it in Rim Stone
on it there's support barers back to the point
Martinez Dem marous a one touch to the front of
the net a little redirect by eel oh alone able
to get just enough to put it between the pads
of San quick passing and result back of the
net eichel's 19th and the Golden Heights get on
the board and have the one- nothing lead de Swan
got a piece of that at Center R geeki plays it
in cter almost lost it dead losing and Thompson
bailed him out with a big save on keki there's a
look as Conor just is trying to bring it back and
as he tries to bring just loses it Thompson the
initial save and then it goes right to geeki in
front and good awareness by Logan Thompson right
there to Spring in action and he's moving to his
right and he throws that blocker out in time
on Dei the result of the game but beyond that
as well guys yeah Bruce gass's talk about that
Ashley gzz a WR shot deflected score and may have
been tipped in on the way to the net rist let go
for the left point and the Bruins have tied the
game now what like a change direction somewhere
grizzli just walked in from that left Point
here's a look at the play Oh doesn't get out
kept alive grizzli the shot and it looks like
it catches a piece of Martinez possibly and
just change direction watch this Puck there
right off Martinez stick it was heading to that
left side side goes back to the right on Thompson
and grizzli ties it up and Thompson holds tight
Frederick trying to center it h pinballs around to
the crease and a mato behind the Vegas net eel on
the counter attack with barers shf coming eel with
a wrist shot deflected over the net m l r Stone
the patr Alo his drive hit low R barers and he had
it stopped in front looked like lindhall made the
save as he lets it Go the one-time from the blue
line and it does and here's Barbers and there's
the right pad of s and stretched out to make the
stop oh great save by San flashed up that right
pad to Rob barbashev lry paid the price blocked
the initial chance from petrangelo and then
swammer with a tremendous stop on barers
Jack eel sitting one goal away
from 200 in his NHL career now
stone cutting through Center Ice into the Zone
with petrangelo stone looking to petrangelo he
scores Alex petrangelo second of the season
from Mark Stone it's a two to one overtime
win and it's poer knock that's going
to lose coverage watch right here on
Stone as he darts forward petrang comes
up there's the two onone and the patient
F Stone outweights Lindo and great pass
to Alex petrano to leave him a tap in he
freezes lindol he freezes San and gets the
pass through to petrangelo puts it to the
back of the net his second of the season
and a huge win here for the golden knights